Michelle for the koffsky showed up at
Berlin's museum at Checkpoint Charlie
early in the morning he looked fit and
refreshed for a man who just emerged
from a decade in prison there were
hundreds of journalists on hand for the
event Burakovsky said that he was taken
aback by the huge media interest
most people came hoping to find out
about the one-time threat to Russian
President Vladimir Putin will do next
but he was unable to be specific kakita
by plans for the future I just don't
know yet as a prisoner you can only
really hold it you don't know what is
possible and what is not possible but
when asked about his feelings now
towards Putin he was cautious uh yeah
which in my hope Western politicians
will remember is that I will not be the
last political prisoner in Russia Shay's
they will have to decide how to deal
with him in them boom niche bro stupid
auto kofsky says he will now fight for
the freedom of other people who are
unjustly behind bars in Russia but from
a place in Berlin which one symbolized
the border between the east and west he
also said he had no plans to enter the
political arena